[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous dans 16
autres cas dit ce matin nathalie jos est
notre invité bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous l'intelligence membres du parti ou
du mouvement martinique citoyenne alors
l'actualité bas ce matin c'est ça y est
les dates des élections territoriales
pour nous qui sont fixés 13 et 22 juin
et 20 juin plutôt le report du scrutin
où c était dans l'air à cause de
l'épidémie de covile 19 donc on peut
raisonnablement supposer nathalie josse
que les grandes manoeuvres
la campagne électorale va commencer
après la période des jours grade de
carnaval est justement de ce point de
vue avec quelques-uns de vos amis
politiques vous étiez le mois dernier au
meeting de rentrée de pays a alors cette
présence de deux membres cette présence
quand même bien bien afficher un demande
de martinique citoyenne signifie tel un
ralliement justement de votre parti à la
bannière de ce parti pire alors ben pour
les élections municipales on avait déjà
été avec sous la bannière avec payant
donc on a fait un bout de chemin avec
eux donc sur cette campagne des
municipales à fort de france et donc
c'est une continuité
oui on on est en discussion
discutons sur les programmes sur
plusieurs projets sur notre façon de
voir la politique est en fait pour nous
pays à c'est ce qui se rapproche un peu
plus de nos convictions de nos valeurs
donc voilà oui donc les élections de la
ctm les fort probable que vous vous
retrouviez ensemble sur sur une liste
alors sur le fond qu'est-ce que vous
avez tirer comme enseignement des
discours qui ont été prononcées par les
leaders de deux pays à que trouvez-vous
intéressant dans le positionnement de
fond de ce potentiel allié vous venez de
le confirmer
et bien en fait pour nous donc comme je
vous le disais c'est ce qui se rapproche
un peu de ce que nous croyons être des
valeurs politiques c'est-à-dire s'élever
au dessus des querelles politiques
renouveler
le personnel politique aussi et pour ne
rien vous cacher ce qui nous a encore le
plus convaincu aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement le discours de marcelin
nadeau sur le statut de l'élu
marcellin nadeau qui a déclaré qu'il
n'allait pas se représenter une
quatrième fois au prêcheur il l'a dit et
pour nous c'est extrêmement important
parce que c'est vraiment notre nouveau
combat vous savez nous avons mené
beaucoup de combats en martinique
citoyenne
quand nous avons commencé à parler de
démocratie participative d'implication
du citoyen bon nous avons été en butte à
beaucoup de quolibets le citoyen le
citoyen aujourd'hui ça y est c'est fait
ce sont des idées qui sont entrés et
tout le monde se revendique même si on
est loin de l'application générale on
est loin dans les fêtes de la
représentation du citoyen mais tout le
monde aujourd'hui a conscience et c'est
que il faut mettre le citoyen au centre
des débats
même si le chemin est encore long
lorsque nous avons parlé de transport
gratuit aussi et tout le monde oui non
c'est pas réaliste et sait aujourd'hui
tout le monde parle du transport gratuit
et c'est dommage justement que martin
transport pense aujourd'hui à remettre
le transport payant je pense qu'il ya
moyen de faire autrement
et donc c'est pour ça que sur toutes ces
valeurs là sur le statut de l'élu
particulièrement nous allons beaucoup
insister parce qu'il faut arrêter de
professionnaliser la politique et ça
c'est très important pour nos bas on
voit déjà un thème de campagne qui est
en train de naître puisque le président
du conseil exécutif sortant alfred marie
jeanne pour le nommer a décidé de se
représenter alors on en pense ce qu'on
veut
à tort ou à raison c'est les électeurs
qui décideront mais il tente de
renouveler donc un mandat à la ctm après
une longévité politique quand même
évidemment bien bien marquer alors c'est
ça je vous le disais ça va être notre
combat principal c'est de voilà notre
nouveau champ de bataille c'est ça parce
qu'il faut absolument pour renouer la
confiance contre les élus et les
citoyens
il faut absolument s'arrêter sur ça
c'est à dire que cette longévité des
élus
il faut il faut arrêter je pense que
avoir ses mandats qui n'en finissent pas
il ya des jeunes qui naissent et qui ne
connaissent que que les mêmes élus on ne
s'en sort pas il n'ya aujourd'hui que
les mêmes qui reste en place
on ne fait pas de jeunisme il ne s'agit
pas de dire il faut mettre des jeunes il
faut mettre des femmes non il faut
absolument si on veut retrouver la
confiance des citoyens renouveler la
classe politique et il faut qu'on sente
de cette classe politique qu'il reste en
place et qui accapare en fait le pouvoir
il ya un véritable lac apparemment
kidnapping du pouvoir ici une espèce de
consanguinité des élus et il faut
véritablement finir si on veut que
renouveler la classe
on voit déjà ce qui se profile un petit
peu comme thème que vous allez apporter
dans la corbeille de l'alliance avec
pays à part et vous pensez que ça c'est
une forte attente de la part de la
population de l'électorat en mars libre
absolument je crois qu'en secteur social
tout à fait il y en a qui disent que la
native soit crédible pour ne plus faire
confiance à des équipes en fait c'est
vraiment là que parce que le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas d alternative le fait que
l'algérie td pouvoir fait que on a du
mal à faire émerger une nouvelle
alternative et comme elle n'est pas là
donc voilà les citoyens ne se retrouve
pas et on s'en sort pas les mêmes
toujours les mêmes et ils en ont assez
et ça fait des taux d'abstention énormes
qui vont continuer de grimper
ouais alors martinique citoyenne avec un
pareil non on s'attendait peut-être à ce
que vous montiez davantage au créneau
avec ce qui s'est passé par rapport aux
derniers rebondissements judiciaires
vous savez concernant le le dossier
chlordécone
alors comment le percevez-vous est ce
que vous allez peut-être davantage vous
affichez monté au créneau là dessus avec
un nom pareil
ben écoute et on s'est toujours
intéressé 1
au chlordécone nous nous n'avons nous
sommes dans tout les associer à dit que
nous travaillons avec tout le monde nous
avons nous sommes en discussion en ce
moment vous savez il ya beaucoup de
discussions à la maison des syndicats
avec tous les syndicats tous les partis
y avait une part de city ceux qui
préparent la mobilisation là de la fin
de ce volume nous avons fait nous nous
avons fait quelques réunions nous sommes
nous avons participé au débat qui était
très constructif malgré certaines
dissensions mais on arrive à un
consensus et donc nous sommes arrêtés
sous la date du samedi 27 vous dire non
à son non lieu qui est absolument
criminelle à son non lieu qui est
vraiment une gifle pour pop ou les
antillais et donc oui c'est un combat
donc dans lequel vous êtes dans le
collectif qui veut justement à résister
face à ça mais bien sûr alors vous êtes
aussi conseillère municipale de fort de
france vous avez été élu lors des
dernières élections de l'année dernière
alors conseiller municipal minoritaire
ou de l'opposition
presqu'un an de la deuxième mandature de
didier laguerre n'est son équipe
municipale
alors plutôt que de faire un bilan
général un an après je sais que tout
récemment vous avez pris position sur
une question d'aménagement du territoire
et vous dites ville de fort de france un
modèle de mal développement même s'il
est nécessaire de se loger le plus grand
nombre multiplié les logements sociaux
et très sociaux est une ineptie dire que
vous qu'est ce qu'on dirait que ça n'a
pas de sens quoi c'est en termes de
bien-être de vivre ensemble de sécurité
d'abord économique avec à l'heure vous
souligner que c'est souvent fait avec un
un système de défiscalisation avec la
défiscalisation des logements sociaux
seuls les promoteurs y trouvent leur
compte aujourd'hui vous parler de
véritable catastrophe sociale et
économique que l'on prépare pour les
années à venir donc faut arrêter de
faire du logement social à fort de
france c'est quand même c'est pas ce que
je dis maman la manière dont c'est fait
voilà c'est la manière dont c'est fait
ça dit que toute la pegi de faux la
périphérie de fort-de-france si vous
voulez on développe des logements
sociaux
on l'a bien dit on je suis bien
consciente qu'il lui faut loger les gens
aient un véritable parce que moi deux
ans tant en tant que personnel politique
ce qu'on me demande le plus c'est du
travail et du logement
les gens ils ont absolument besoin
d'emploi et de logement c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'il faut les loger
mais il faut pas les loger à n'importe
quel prix
que le remède peut être plus plus plus
plus plus plus mauvais que le calme
aujourd'hui lorsque vous mettez
hautement de logements sociaux dans une
dans une périphérie
au final vous développez vous mettez en
place d'aidés que vous auriez voulu
comment vous comment pourrait-on faire
différemment
eh bien il faut il faut mettre du
logement social il faudrait mieux le
répartir peut-être en me dire oui mais
il ya des quartiers qui ne veulent pas
de logement social oui il faut aller
vers la mixité sociale
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui marche le mieux
essayer le plus que possible
il faut oser il faut avoir du courage
vous dire il faut mettre des logements
sociaux dans la la la la la banlieue bon
j'aime pas ce terme ait omis
présidentielle face à vous créer des
ghettos sociaux toutes parts et de créer
des ghettos sursis au final fausses
voilà à parquer les gens et mettre des
ghettos sociaux à la fin c'est vraiment
une ineptie économique c'est une ineptie
sociale parce que ça fait beaucoup de
dégâts sociaux dans la france
on le ressent beaucoup il par exemple un
sujet comme ça si vous le portez en
conseil municipal est ce que vous
arrivez à développer vos arguments
est-ce que absolument pas bon parce
qu'on n'est pas très entendus sur ce
sujet là parce qu'ils ont leur plan
d'aménagement qu'ils vont mettre en
place de toutes les façons mais il faut
le dire il faut alors peut-être qu'ils
peuvent entendre qu'ils peuvent
réfléchir un moment puis se dire ouais
peut-être parce que c'est pas bon
peut-être qu'il faut selon jean d'août
mais l'onglet selon moi que citoyen loin
bien entendu mais je pense qu'il ya un
accompagnement social il faut repenser
le logement social
en tous les cas en ce qui concerne
l'aménagement du centre ville de
fort-de-france
parce que si vous ne mettez que du
logement social sans jamais faire venir
des classes actives des classes qui ont
les moyens des classes quand des revenus
donc ça fait fuir en fait cette classe
qui peut apporter une naissance
économique qui peut apporter un
bien-être économique voilà qui a des
revenus donc je pense que la mixité
sociale c'est véritablement ça qui porte
ses fruits et il nous faudrait perdu
mais nous faut qu'on il nous faut
conclure
l'intelligence martinique citoyenne
alors les citoyens d'ici une chose qui
les préoccupent aussi en ce moment c'est
comment va-t-on faire le carnaval
notamment pour les jours gras qui arrive
là c'est la semaine prochaine je sais
pas ce que vous même vous avez
l'intention de participer à quelques
vides et peut-être qu'on vous
reconnaîtra pas masqué mais voilà quelle
est votre position sur cette question
éminemment sociétal mais qui touche à
nos us et coutumes tout à fait moi
j'adore le carnaval c'est vraiment moi
un moment mais mécano balle mais ma mère
les cui vide et tout mais je pense qu'il
ya un principe de précaution a impliqué
ben voilà il ya un virus qui circulent
on ne sait pas vraiment dissocier le
vrai du faux donc trouver un équilibre
maintenir et je pense qu'il faut
s'abstenir et qu'il faut essayer bombes
et de voir comment on peut peut-être le
reporter à plus tard peut-être
et puis je pense que l'a320 l'idée de
faire un grand carnaval au stade là un
peu dans un pourquoi pas ça c'est leur
idée enfin bon moi ça me voilà pourquoi
s'il ya des gens qui sont plus avoir en
son nom mais voilà et je pense que le
principe de précaution doit le respecter
voilà et on le fera et peut-être qu'on
le fera deux fois mieux l'année
prochaine inspirant que voilà on sera
débarrassé des barons va on va on va
conclure sur cette note d'espoir
finalement peut-être un carnaval normal
la semaine prochaine il faut l'espérer
dans les prochaines heures et prochains
voiliers votre âge jusqu'aux sert pas à
l'année prochaine
merci bonne journée